welcome to the Mass Effect Andromeda
gameplay series a Mass Effect Andromeda
you are the Pathfinder the ultimate
adventure and a vast unexplored galaxy
on a mission to find a new home for
Humanity can you make it somewhere
tropical nice warm ocean some are you
around our first video we'll take a look
at weapons and skills Andromeda's action
is built around fluid fast paced
third-person combat our combat offers
amazing freedom of movement with the use
of a Jump Jet that allows you to jump
evade and even hover while you're
fighting you'll also notice a new
dynamic cover system allows you to
seamlessly use almost anything including
your own vehicle for cover all this
freedom allows you to approach the
battle in a way that suits your gameplay
style let's take a closer look at our
weapons I'm aspect and drama there are
four categories of guns pistols shotguns
and sniper an assault rifles plus a
range of melee weapons for up close
combat all guns are available to every
player there are no class restrictions
so if you decide you want to try
something new it's as easy as switching
your load up guns and gear and Andromeda
fall into three technology types based
on where the tech comes from Milky Way
weapons typically use physical
projectile ammunition that's similar to
the types of weapons you might be
familiar with from our original games
with some advancements of course these
are high impact projectile based guns
they're great against most non shielded
targets but require you to keep an eye
on your ammo
Remi weapons typically use beams have a
high rate of fire and extremely accurate
the easy overheat system and don't rely
on ammo so you'll never run out of ammo
but you'll have to wait for your gun to
cool down from time to time Ilyas
weapons are technology from
civilizations of living the Helius
cluster of Andromeda they're generally
plasma-based which means they're slower
speed but benefit from heat-seeking
technology while summer charge base the
longer you charge them before releasing
the heart of the hit melee weapons Barry
in both damage and speed are hitting
hammers do maximum damage a lightning
fast ships or swords allow you to get in
and out of harm's way with maximum speed
and precision in addition to weapons you
can also develop skills and abilities
like the weapons are no restrictions on
what skills you can choose and each of
the three main categories is designed to
facilitate a certain style of play
combat skills are great if you want to
focus on weapons gear and making your
character the ultimate soldier these
skills focus on improving weapon damage
and accuracy as well as giving you the
ability to use flat cannons grenades
trip mines and more tech skills allow
you to equip your pathfinder with more
experimental weaponry or focus on
strategic improvements for you and your
squad cryo beam and flame tour give you
more offensive punch while skills like
invasion or energy drain weaken your
opponents and make them easier to take
down
one a little extra help deploy your own
assault turret last but not least
biotics by controlling dark energy your
pathfinder can harness the power of mass
and gravity biotic skills like pull and
throw allow you to literally control the
battlefield using your enemies as a
shield leave in a weapon abilities like
an i elation shield or singularity can
disrupt and damage anything or anyone
caught up in their powerful grip each
skill can be upgraded to become
increasingly more devastating and
effective each also has choices to make
when upgrading offering you more ways to
customize your play style now that we
have the basics down let's put this into
action in this case our Pathfinder is
equipped with a sniper rifle and a
shotgun and they've got their three
powers selected you'll notice the
different enemies each behave in unique
ways some will keep their distance and
try to snipe us others will charge right
in and try to flush us out a cover
sticky grenades is an advanced version
of the Omni grenade combat skill they're
effective against just about anything
but they have a limited supply enemies
each have different strengths and
weaknesses for most headshots inflict
maximum damage but you'll need to pay
attention to the health bars yellow
means they've got armor and won't be as
susceptible to certain weapons and
powers Blue means they're shielded and
in addition to being more resistant to
biotics you'll generally need to deal
with those shields before their health
goes down and just like you their
shields will recharge if you don't
finish them off quickly tactical cloak
is a tech skill that allows you to evade
enemy detection and inflict increase
damage when attacking from cloak and
finally overload another tech skill is
great for taking out enemies shields and
synthetic enemies by holding it before
releasing you can even chain it to
multiple enemies and this is just one of
the hundreds of combinations of weapons
and skills you can try and end drama de
stay tuned for future installments but
we'll show you our profiles to give you
an added boost in combat favorites which
allow you immediate access to your sets
of power so you can change up on the fly
and squad skills and commands
you
[Music]
[Music]